Ernest Sanders Freddie gray who comes to
the USA women's soccer Caitlyn Jenner
hover balls explode Donald Trump says
something tasteless Donald Trump says
something racist katafanga drop hello
Justin Trudeau
Mad Max if lady boss Syria dollars on
Clinton's missing emails El Chapo
escapes from jail
IRA deal antibac Baron and Paris attack
tricks bad Tastee Poppy's happy bail
goodbye 2015 it was pretty crappy will
next year be happy
goodbye 2015 it was pretty bad except
the pizza rat Cuba refugees Kim Davis
and Huckabee
black lives matter that Confederate flag
random dentist kills a line and B ceases
by the bright Greek debt crisis jeb
Bush's slogans fan hitchbot climate
talks on that's got a winning clock Josh
Duggar Sandra bland Boston bomber takes
the stand fifa startups are Jon Stewart
Deez Nuts earthquakes bathroom pegs
Christmas come from Starbucks cups
goodbye 2015 if you read the news you
probably had the blues goodbye 2015
there are wrongs and rights and many non
indictments Game of Thrones Horgan stone
Walter Scott no Keystone will kasnia
disgrace of bombers seems amazing grace
Love Wins Germanwings Kanye was for
president everyone gave this cutoff you
ain't no Muslim rough
Back to the Future day liquid thus a
major shake El Nino Robert Durst Marge
Kelly is the worst food in me just sweet
Charlie goodbye one kid policy blown and
pecky yeah but this stupid dress has
called him white goodbye 2015 yes this
year was held at least we had Adele
goodbye 2015 there were yeas and nays in
Fifty Shades of Grey
Viola Davis water on Mars cheating with
Volkswagen cars Miley Cyrus Serena
Williams Star Wars emoji diversity Tracy
Richards - TV Roseburg Charleston and
Colorado Springs Chapel Hill Lafayette
San Bernardino guns kill people every
day what else do I have to say goodbye
2015 what a weird lucky we're glad
you're all still here
goodbye 2015 if you think it was bad
just remember these cash
you